well I should have known that last week
would be interesting it began in an
unusual way on Sunday I was uh leaving
church with three of my kids in tow and
as I was walking towards the car I heard
someone shout my name from behind me and
I you know I get flagged down by fans on
the way out of church pretty frequently
as you might expect the church going
crowd is my core demographic so I didn't
think it was anything you know out of
the ordinary and the guy ran up shook my
hand started making friendly small talk
but then his tone changed suddenly and
he told me that actually he thinks that
my work has a terrible impact on the
world he said that this church the one
the one we just came out of is a place
of love not hate and I'm not welcome
there
now I responded in knowing certain terms
that he can't speak to me that way in
front of my children and that he should
be ashamed of himself he turned around
and walked hurriedly away and that was
the end of the conversation
now I hoped that my kids who were
standing there hadn't been paying
attention maybe and maybe didn't realize
what the guy said to me I was hoping
perhaps it didn't register on them
but when we got to the car my son
started to cry and he asked me why that
mean man said those things and I
explained to him that there are people
in this world
who don't like it when you speak the
truth and when you try to do what's
right their hearts are shrouded in
darkness and they hate the light just as
the Bible says
I tried to act unfazed for the sake of
my kids but the truth is that I was
extremely angry I don't care what you
say about me or to me but you've crossed
a line when you make my boy cry
but it was an important lesson for him
to learn and for me to relearn in
preparation for the week ahead
so on Monday afternoon I was informed
that YouTube was demonetizing my channel
and this was the first step towards a
possible permanent demonetization or
banishment from the platform entirely
YouTube keeps its rules intentionally
vague that's the way they play the game
they'll they'll penalize you for
violating their policies and yet they
won't explain exactly what their
policies are
so the company gives itself the license
to single anybody out for whatever
reasons they decide they accused me of
engaging in hateful conduct which
supposedly ran afoul of both their
Community guidelines and their ads
guidelines they already took the step of
deleting a number of my offending
episodes which are gone now from YouTube
um which is something that again they
did on their own and now they're taking
away our ads which is a penalty of more
than a hundred thousand dollars per
month that's what it adds up to
now they provided us with just three
examples of my infractions and these
aren't these aren't all of them uh they
said but they told us about three and uh
they wouldn't tell us why they were in
fractions but they they said that um you
know they told us what three of them
were and they said all three of them had
to do with Dylan Mulvaney coincidentally
and they all seem to involve the crime
of quote unquote misgendering so for
example
one of the violations occurred when I
referred to Mulvaney as a quote guy
that was a violation
and what you should know is that we were
not flagged by the algorithm okay it's
not one of those algorithmic glitches
and this does not appear to be some
low-level decision at the company either
yet a path to remonetization is
available it seems that we can get back
into YouTube's good graces uh get our
monetization back by simply respecting
preferred pronouns and refraining from
offering any meaningful critiques of
gender ideology in other words all I
have to do
to get all that back is forfeit my
integrity and betray all of my deep
deepest held principles
that's it now not to skip ahead but I
can tell you right now that my answer to
that offer is not only no but hell no
the next day shortly after I finished
eating dinner with my family
I noticed that my Twitter account had
been logged out on my computer
and I tried to log back in but the
password didn't work and that's when I
knew that I was hacked so I grabbed my
phone to call my team about it but my
phone had stopped working at the precise
moment when the Twitter hack happened
and that's when I knew that the hack
went far beyond Twitter
as we would soon find out the hacker had
pulled off a maneuver known as Sim
swapping and that's a thing where the
targets you know the person who's being
targeted your phone number is
transferred over to a SIM card that the
hacker controls and once they have your
number and your sim card they can access
almost anything and this hacker did he
got into my text messages my DMs my
emails everything
leftists and trans activists were giddy
they were cheering on the attack They
begged for my private messages to be
released they said that I deserved to be
the victim of this federal crime at
least one journalist openly solicited my
stolen information
put out his email address and asked the
asked for my stolen DMS and my stole
information to be sent to him to be
emailed to him the hacker then did an
interview uh with this same journalist
who works for the publication wired the
hacker apparently showed the journalists
my tax documents showed him some of my
pictures uh some of my old emails
the article directly quotes one of my
private emails that would contained
nothing salacious or even mildly
interesting in fact uh it was a a
friendly exchange I had with Stephen
Crowder 10 years ago and this made it
into the wired article for some reason
facts and logic are precious Rarities in
this mad mad world of ours but do you
know what is even more precious than
facts and logic precious metals when the
economy is in turmoil and the stock
market is tanking
there's only one thing you can count on
that's precious metals Birch gold is the
only company I trust to help me invest
in physical gold and silver they have
everything you need to protect your
money in an unstable economic climate
they'll even help you convert your
existing Ira or 401K into a tax
sheltered IRA and precious metals when
you invest with Birch gold you'll be
protecting your savings from inflation
and economic uncertainty I buy gold from
Birch gold because I want a financial
safety net for my family you could do
the same text Walsh to 98 98 98 to get a
free info kit on gold and start
investing in your financial future today
with an A plus rating With Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is the company that I
trust to protect my future and yours so
text Walsh to 989898 today the only
interesting Revelation in the article is
that the hacker says that he had help in
pulling off this hack from an
unspecified quote-unquote Insider
and we have independently as we've been
tracking this down we've independently
found other evidence which also points
in that direction that there was help
from an Insider
however exactly he did it and whoever
helped him and we will find all this out
I promise you
it resulted in something much worse than
the mere headache of somebody posting
dumb tweets from my account this was a
total violation of our privacy and if
I'm being completely honest with you it
was one of the worst things that my
family has ever experienced
um I didn't sleep that night I was up
with our security team our Tech Guys
lawyers trying to put off put out a
dozen fires all at once through the
following day we had people on the phone
with Microsoft Apple Google Twitter my
cell phone carrier the FBI local law
enforcement Etc
it was a nightmare even with all these
resources available to me the fact that
I can that we the we can just get on the
phone with all these different companies
and try to solve this problem even with
that it's a nightmare I I can't imagine
what this kind of attack is like for
people who aren't so fortunate you know
if you're stuck in a situation where all
you can do is call 1-800 numbers then um
that's going to make it all the worst
on Wednesday with no sleep I flew to the
University of Iowa to deliver a speech
in front of what turned out to be a
massive sold out crowd a lot of energy
in the room which gave me enough of a
boost to get through the event without
passing out on stage or you know
descending into incoherent Joe Biden
mumbles outside there were throngs of
protesters taken to the streets they
were stopping traffic they were blocking
the exits out of the event
they also dumped thousands of marbles in
the hallway outside of the auditorium
where the event was taking place in
hopes of you know making people slip and
fall and causing Serious injury to
hundreds of people as they're walking
out fortunately that plan failed
so to summarize it was a difficult week
but also fully in keeping with my
experience over the past year or more
especially since my film what is a woman
came out we have been doxxed threatened
stalked harassed almost constantly
the threats became severe and frequent
enough shortly after the film came out
to necessitate 24-hour armed security in
our home
last night there was a Reddit post which
went viral from somebody calling me a
homophobic Nazi and saying that I should
be murdered the poster said that he's
quote tired of me getting away with this
and when he says getting away with it
what he's talking about is that I'm
getting away with expressing my beliefs
openly he's tired of that and he said
that there needs to be consequences
quote unquote the consequences he
specifies should involve me being
bludgeoned to death with a baseball bat
and the thing is that this is not the
sentiment of just one random weirdo on
Reddit
in fact somebody posted something
similar to Twitter a few weeks ago
saying that I should be tortured and
killed and it got tens of thousands of
likes and thousands of supportive
comments
there is a wide consensus on the left
that I deserve to be killed and they
have made that point abundantly clear
but the good news is that we're not
taking any of this lying down
I'm going to be working with law
enforcement I am working with law
enforcement right now to ensure that the
person who hacked into my phone and
anybody who granted him access is
punished to the full extent of the law
we are going to sue everybody involved
I can't say much more about it right now
except that many different wheels are
currently in motion and if the people
who did this aren't nervous right now
they should be
on the YouTube front
um
as long as they make affirmation of
gender ideology a prerequisite for
posting my show on the platform I will
not post my show on the platform
but I also will not allow myself to be
banished Into Obscurity off to some
internet ghetto where nobody will find
my content you see big Tech
this is the choice they want us to make
they want they want me either to
surrender my principles
or become irrelevant
and they'll be happy with whichever of
those two options I choose either one
fine with them
which is why I choose neither
instead starting today we're going to
make this show available to everyone for
free on The Daily wire it'll also be
available on Rumble Apple podcast
Spotify all the other places you
normally get your podcast and we're
trying something new as well starting
today every episode of the show will
also be posted in full on Twitter which
is now the most powerful Free Speech
platform in the world and it seems like
the place where this show belongs if you
if you follow our Channel on YouTube you
can still find plenty of content that
we'll make specially for you we'll still
post clips from the show so we can reach
new audiences with our message but we're
not going to give YouTube our full show
so long as the situation remains as it
is
I'm sure you can go to Brazil or
Colombia and get crazy things done to
your face but why on Earth would you do
that if you're tired of dealing with
puffy eye bags dry skin and wrinkles
then it's time to start taking your
skincare routine seriously and check out
my friends at genucel skin care just in
time for their Mother's Day special
genucel is offering 70 off their most
popular package our Studios Tech manager
Patrick has known around the office for
having a glorious head of hair really
Prides himself in his long and flowing
locks but because he's been so focused
on maintaining his hair he completely
forgot to take care of his skin his skin
became his splotchy oily horrendous
Nightmare and it sickened me to the
deepest parts of my soul so like I
always do I forced him to try genucel's
wide range of projects and now Patrick's
skin is as beautiful as his hair one of
the products that he used was genu sales
Ultra retinol which helps exfoliate the
skin and can reduce the appearance of
pores and improve skin texture it can
also help to even out skin tone by
reducing the appearance of age spots and
hyperpigmentation if you don't want your
mother to look the way Patrick used to
get the gift of flawless skin this
Mother's Day visit gendercell.com Walsh
to save over 70 off their most popular
package this package includes the docs
Dark Spot Corrector as well as their
Ultra retinol and under eye treatment
you'll get a complimentary Spa
Essentials box with every order from now
until Mother's Day plus a free upgrade
to priority shipping so go to
genucel.com Walsh genucel.com Walsh
the point is that we're not going to
capitulate
but we also aren't going to scale down
and become obsolete
instead we're going to be bigger we're
going to be more Innovative we're going
to reach more people in more ways on
more platforms that's our response
and this is just the beginning I'll have
more to announce soon also we've been
talking with Congress uh YouTube
shouldn't be allowed legally
to hold its users to standards of
conduct that it refuses to properly
explain it's not just this is what
people need to understand it's not just
that they target conservative voices
which they do and that's bad enough on
its own
but that they do it in this incredibly
underhanded way with intentionally
ambiguous rules that are enforced
unevenly according to their opaque
policies that they often seem to be
making up as they go along
the only way this changes is if the
people running YouTube experience a
sudden and mysterious bout of integrity
or if the law forces it to change
and I'm not betting on the former so
instead I'll fight for the latter and I
will take the fight all the way to
Capitol Hill
now there is a point at the end of this
whole Saga the point is that uh one of
the most important points anyway is that
the term culture War
is no mere metaphor
it's certainly not anymore we are up
against people who have no interest in
debates
no interest in discussion
if you oppose them they will not engage
with your arguments they will simply try
to silence you and ruin you
there will be no rebuttals except for
the ones that they issue in the form of
censorship death threats and worse
the more that they perceive that you are
a threat
the more they will work to destroy you
and everyone associated with you
that's the way it works
but this should not dissuade us okay we
shouldn't be discouraged by the
viciousness of our opponents but
motivated by it
it couldn't possibly be more clear who
is on the wrong side and who is on the
right side
this is about as black and white as a
cultural divide can possibly get there
is one side that hates the truth rejects
the truth in principle
and wishes total Destruction on everyone
who speaks it
all you have to do is choose the side
that is not that side
now it may require courage to take that
kind of stand but at least you'll know
where to stand
there's not any confusion about this
as for my ongoing ordeal or ordeals I I
should say
um
I didn't tell you all of it so that you
would feel sorry for me okay pity is the
last thing that I want I chose this line
of work I chose to be in this fight I
went into with my eyes open
okay I knew what I was getting into I
may get hit with a curveball on occasion
I may be introduced to New Concepts like
Sim swapping for example
but mostly I'm getting exactly what I
expected from The Vicious bloodthirsty
rage mob and its leaders in big Tech
and it has not dissuaded me even
slightly
I still will not back down by an inch or
compromise at all
I've told you many times that I would
rather be dead than surrender to these
people and I meant it
so to all the people who are sending me
death threats
and posting my home address
and hacking my accounts
and trying to Blackmail me and threaten
me
giving away my personal information Mass
reporting me to get me D platformed and
all the rest of it
I want you to know that nothing you have
done or will do or could do
will ever make me shut up it will never
happen
none of your schemes have worked or can
ever work it is all futile your efforts
are hopeless
the truth is the truth
and I will never pretend otherwise
I am not here to make a martyr of myself
I don't want any of the good guys to be
martyrs
I want us to win
and we will
that'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]